une attitude vous si vous regardez les
ennemis qu'il y un spectacle bien
s'adapter ami qu'est ce que c'est ils
ont casimir qu'est ce qui t'arrive
quoiqu'une devine pas bah non non je
vois pas tentant alors commencera que
manches à une
tu essaies de te gratter le dos un comme
ça à la non non non pas du tout c'est
pas ça non alors continue continue
ah oui mais tu cherche à écraser un
moustique qui t'a piqué là ça parce que
tu n'as rien compris
regarde moi bien grave si je crois que
tu répètes amine pour la fête de l'école
c'est ça mais non ce n'est pas ça du
tout je me prépare à mon futur métier
un futur métier tu veux dire de cassis
mûre que tu veux travailler
ouais et alors ben bassat sait très bien
que c'est bien bravo bravo et mais dis
donc qu'est ce que tu veux faire non pas
tu n'as pas lu le journal de l'île aux
enfants ce matin et si ces biens seront
alors qu'il n'a pas vus par un titre en
première page
à tort à oui je me souviens il y avait
un gros titres là il y avait marqué
qu'on demandait des candidats pour être
le premier astronaute de l'île aux
enfants aller sur la lune
ouais et didon audiogram dire que tu
veux aller sur la lune comme astronaute
buzz et 1026 et alors
mais enfin casimir t/t beaucoup trop
gros et puis tu sais il faut être très
très très très savants quoi très
intelligent je suis gros mais tu me dis
ça parce que tu es jaloux
nous allons mener au japon quand j'aurai
fini mon entraînement je saurai de
meilleur astronautes du monde tu sais
casimir parmi nous il ya peut-être aussi
d'autres candidats et puis si j'ai une
petite idée que le jour où la fusée
décollera de l'île aux enfants avec des
astronautes à bord eh ben c'est pas pour
demain et tous autant qu'on y est on a
le temps de grandir
tu crois mais c'est très bien on va
pouvoir s'entraîner tous ensemble c'est
ça c'est ça notre stop ça casimir les
enfants les alexandre eric est vite vite
par la la mettez-vous par là où on va
s'entraîner pour être à la hauteur
est-ce que parmi vous il y en a qui
aimeraient astronautes astronautes pour
aller dans la lune nathalie là tu
aimerais
oui la concurrence à tous tous ouvriers
les dans la lune oh là là alors je vous
pose une question et à vous aussi chez
vous et je vous pose une question est ce
que vous savez quand pour la première
fois l'homme a posé le pied sur la lune
vous savez ouais ya pas très longtemps
il ya combien de temps y'a pas longtemps
c'est vrai que j'aime et je donne la
réponse
eh bien il ya cinq ans cinq ans c'était
le 16 juillet 1969
ah ouais au cours du vol apollo 11 et
comment s'appelait l'astronaute celui
qui dirigeait l'expédition à nicolas
armstrong a mis son prénom est l'âme
strong et commence à l'appeler ses deux
coéquipiers eux
et bien il y avait aldrin et collins ans
les trois étaient américains serait
quasiment d'affaires combiné quelque
chose de beaucoup plus mystérieux encore
si la face cachée de la lune c'est quand
on est sur terre on va toujours la même
face de la lune vous saviez mais en
novembre 1959
les russes ont tous mis un satellite qui
s'appelle unique 3 est l'unique 3 a pris
une photographie de la face cachée de la
lune
voilà j'ai bien compris c'est sûr alors
fait une démonstration un pouce et vous
laissez nous ta place on pousse la place
qu'ont beaucoup de places d'honneur ont
vachement aux astronautes
c'est ce qu'ont fait quasiment non moi
je suis le soleil un voyez cela car les
rayons là qui brille devrait chauffe
l'a1 et casimir toi tu vas faire la
terre perd alors comment la terre tourne
hôtels autour du soleil
comment alors tourner je t'explique tu
tournes thomas retourne au tour de main
voilà c'est ça et en même temps qui
monte sur toi même à la halle à la
rotation massaguet de la terre je suis
la terre autour du soleil
je suis amer mais j'ai compris je suis
là
le qatar et les émirats mais toi là où
je me bouge pas admettons que moi
j'habite ici sur la terre au bout du nez
de casimir 1 donc quand le soleil est en
face c'est le jour maintenant quasi me
retourne fait en rotation vous suivez un
beau site stop casimir stocker
signaleurs moi j'habitais au bout du nez
de casimir envoyés maintenant c'est la
nuit pour moi et c'est par ici
le je vous ai compris alors mon nez
120000 de casimir vas-y mon nom c'est là
nous il est bien de l'avenir mon
excellent juillet voila voila c'est la
nuit en mai c'est le jour j aspire
l'ascap on fait autre chose casimir
ouais on fait autre chose tu vas faire
la lune
la rotation de la lune autour de la
terre alors regardez observez bien
regardez bien la russie c'est très
différent parce que la lune autour de la
terre tourne tout autour de la terre
mais sans tourner sur elle-même fait la
rotation comme ça renvoie là là là je
suis la terre je suis la lune
je suis là j je suis la lune la lune au
change si cela était à l'étrat à la
terre la terre
je suis là fait rattraper à les révéler
bien lors pas aussi j'ai du temps avec
moi comme ça tu pourras satellite à la
terre allez allez regarder le spi la
terre c'est la terre je suis la tête
j'allais voir la lune la lune tels aléas
d'une l'allier la ligne pas sur une
telle taille que la terre
je sais que je suis la seule à lui à
l'élu de la baie de la lune pas lui
ouais j'suis solic la terre à terre pour
les faire déferler terre la terre les
terres tu l'as vu de mal alors
je la lui tenait les tue la terre à
terre tu es toi des baptêmes la tête
quand je suis là fait la lutte va faire
vraiment je ne savais pas qu'il y avait
autant de satellites artificiels dans
l'espace